- Au Canada, plus de la moit
des truies passent encore leur
vie dans des cages d'un peu plus
allaitent, elles sont toujours
confinées dans le mêspspspace.
Une réalité dont les principaux
acteurs de l'industrie porcine
de nous parler.
♪ ♪ ♪
Normand Gagné,                e
en se consacrant à l'élevage
de porcs biologique.
NORMAND GAGNÉ, directeur des
- Moi, j'en ai fait,
de l'élevage conventionnel.
Je ne retournerais pas
littéralement, elles se
couchent, elles se lèvent
à l'heure des repas, une fois
se recouchent! Elle fait
des porcelets, puis elle est
prise dans un espace,
pour être le moins cher
possible.
(grognements)
- Ces cages de gestation
au Canada en 2024 afin que
les truies soient élev
en groupe, dans des enclos,
en dehors de leur période
membres de l'industrie
ont eu peur des tstststs
générés par la construction
de porcheries adaptées
Ils ont financé une étude
pour c c c c c'était possible
d'améliorer le bien-être des
truies en les sortant de leur
Cette scientifique a participé
'é'é'é'é'élaboration du protocoe
de recherche.
YOLANDE SEDDON, chercheuse,
Univ. de la Saskatchewan
faisaible dans une porcherie
moderne avec le nombre d'anima
qui s'y trouvent et c'est
un défi. Mais si ce n'est pas
à rien.
- Mais, la sortie hebdomadaire
n'a pas donné les résultats
- Ça n'a pas diminué l'agitation
des amamamamamamélioré leur
confort, parce qu'en dehors
des périodes d'exeelles étaients
dans leur cage.
devraient donc être interdites
en 2029, la nouvelle date butoir
pour les éleveurs de porcs
♪ ♪ ♪
En Suède, l'un des pays
les plus ava
de bien-être animal, les cages
de gestateteteteteteterdites
depuis 35 ans déjà, explique
cette agronome.
TORUN WALLGREN, agronome, Univ.
suédoise des sciences agricoles
- Les cages sont contre nature
pour les truies.nenenenenenene r
leur comportement naturel,
c'est très restrictif.
Vous n'êtes jamais autorisé
à muiuiuiuiuiuiuies en cage,
sauf pour une brève période
de temps. Si elles sont
agressives envers les humains
lelelelelelelets, mais c'est
très inhabituel.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Janette Elander élève
ses truies en groupe à V
au centre de la Suède.
♪ ♪ ♪
JANETTE ELANDER,
élssssssss
- J'aime voir mes truies
en liberté. Je pense que
c'est bon pour leur santé.
rtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtant pour moi.
- Pendant la brève période
où les truies sont en cage
avec leurs porcelets,s s s s s r
et se retourner sans difficulté.
Elles disposent de trois fois
plus d'espace que les truiesélés
de l'Union européenne.
Au Canada, seuls les porcs
élevés en régie biologique
ont des conditions de vie
similaires à ceux de la Suède.
Comme chez Du Breton,
le principal producteur de porcs
biologique en Amérique du Nord.
Ici, quand elles sont avec leurs
porcelets, les truies ont trois
fois plus d'espace qu'en élevage
conventionnel.
- On est dans un enclos de mise
bas. On peut voir la truie
qui est libre de ses mouvements,
qui est capable de se coucher,
de se lever, de se retourner
un peu comme elle veut.
- Mais, à peine 0,5 %
des producteurs canadiens
élèvent des porcs dans ces
conditions, aux standardsn-n-n-.
Ici Julie Vaillancourt,
Radio-Canada, Montréa